[Music]
we were very lucky to have parents who
were
doting and loving really good parents
i remember once being really freaked out
uh when i tried to grab my father's hand
we were at my elementary school and i
had lost track of him and i saw him his
his arms swinging in his big like adult
hands and i went to grab it and he shook
me off and it was such a an unsettling
scary feeling to be shaken off by your
own father and so i went to reach for
his hand again and again he shook me off
and a third time i reached for his hand
and he shook me off and lifted up his
hands and i looked up and i realized it
wasn't my father it was tim schneider's
death
and he was this huge tim schneider was a
big kid he was like a big ginger kid a
friend of mine
i hate to reduce him to that i'm sure
now he's a big ginger man next time you
go to grab my hand i'm going to shake
you away and try to trigger a childhood
trauma it might something weird might
have i know i might start crying well
don't try to grab my hand
you're warned
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
uh you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
with me as always is uh
another source of comfort in my life
like my father's hand was i'll always
hold your hand if you want to hold my
hand i was just kidding about that
thanks it was weird because tim
schneider's dad when i looked up it was
it's strange it's almost like when you
go to drink water when you're expecting
water and you drink vodka or or how
often does that well it's or it's more
when you're like expecting seltzer water
and it's tonic water yes gross or yeah i
guess your analogy was
more extreme more extreme but i just
don't think that happened like when do
you think you're drinking water and you
drink vodka actually tim schneider
wasn't the vodka equivalent of when i
was expecting water as my dad i mean tim
that would be like looking up and seeing
like charles manson yeah man although he
was short i mean i had to i probably
would have been about his size he was a
tall scary person like uh
[Music]
john wayne casey he was pretty tall
right was he i think he was fat oh i
know he's tall maybe like i mean shaq
wouldn't be scary he'd be comforting
he'd be so
he's such a benevolent
i'd be comforted to see him do you think
it'd be weird if tim schneider was
listening to this right now because you
yeah aren't friends with him anymore you
haven't talked to him since you were a
kid which is also strange because i it'd
be strange to see him because he
probably looked just like his dad and my
memories of his dad were that angle me
looking up and
it was a sk as you as we said it was a
scary memory because i thought it was
pot um
tim schneider probably looks a lot like
his dad he's probably very tall he's
probably like six four six five
he was a tall tim he was telling him i
know some tall tim's too you know both
of you told him my best friend growing
up was named tim oh yeah our uncle is
named tim and he's huge he's like six
five i think um i only have isn't that
weird i only have experience with tall
tim you don't know any short tim's i
don't think so except tiny tim and i
don't that's the fictional oh there's
that tim on um from police academy that
the actor was on saturday live tim
i don't know if he has a winski or
something it doesn't matter i don't know
do you know any short term um
no i don't know any short terms tim
now you know another tall tim yes so
that this is why we're talking why are
we talking about tall times
because our guest today is a tall tim
that's basically what he's known for
halton he's known for his height
uh he's also an oscar winner shoe size
he's known for uh much like a past guest
of ours neil degrasse dick grass
oh you gotta find myself wow
self-esteem degrowth
um yeah tim robbins is our uh
guest today and i i hesitate because we
mistakenly keep calling him tom ribbons
so now that that's in all of your heads
you may in fact
mistakenly call him tom ribbons it's
such a fun name it is tom ribbons what
do they call that what's the inversion a
name and version is there a name is
there a there's a term for that um
anyway tim robbins is our guest he's uh
an incredible actor he's he's been a
movie star since i can remember since i
was a kid
and uh his biggest movie was is one of
i think everyone's favorite movies it's
like
shushing redemption is like isn't that
like universally considered
i think if you ask the the older
generation what their favorite movie is
and and they and you get as many times
as you get casablanca or to one in there
or it's a wonderful life yeah or maybe
that's the generation above them but for
as many times as you get that for that
generation i think that's how often you
get shawshank for our generation it's
very rare to be able to safely say that
a movie is a classic
like yeah i mean as much as i love
boogie nights and i would call it a
classic i think but it's i wouldn't i
don't think like our parents would agree
or uncle tim would agree necessarily
that but shawshank crosses generations i
think for everyone that's a classic
even for uncle tim i think so i think
uncle tim would our tall uncle tim would
think it's a classic by the way our
uncle tim we should say because
hopefully he's listening is also very
funny and like he's way more than tall
yes he's one of the funniest people as
his tom ribbons tim robbins tim robbins
is also way more than tall um
and way more than t i mean not way more
than ten they're both in their
respective fields are very accomplished
tim
god i've nev yeah for the rest of my
life that's gonna scream tom ribbons is
a much catchier name maybe that's what
it is tom tim
robbins ribbons also the famous uh
motivational speaker uh tony robbins
tony robbins anyway all right let's get
off the name yeah all right well he's so
tim robinson tim robbins has won an
oscar an acting oscar for mr griffin
uh he has
he has been nominated for a directing
oscar for um dead man walking what
impression is that um i think that's the
guard in dead men walking that's how
they yell
they sound a little like wilford brimley
it did it's the right thing to do it did
the right way to do it wow that's pretty
good thanks so so
he's he's uh he's not an egot but he's
the kind of guy who could be yeah i
wouldn't be surprised because he's a
musician he got vibes he does he has he
has he got energy yeah yeah
i was very excited to meet him he was
very serious as you'll hear but there
were moments of it was fun to make him
laugh it was like a
challenge yeah i felt really
accomplished he's been in so many great
movies i know i don't want him on that
he was in uh bull durham the player
um hudsucker proxy
yeah and and i like he's great in high
fidelity he play he calls now he gives
it
his character he calls a new age douche
or something is really funny he has a
new movie coming out called dark waters
that's right we talk a lot about that so
just to give it context um i had just
seen it it's so first of all it's it's
it's genuinely riveting it's about um
the dupont's scandal i mean it's such a
it was such a major thing and still an
ongoing thing that scandal seems to like
betray how
huge an impact it had on so many
people's lives so
the huge chemical company had been using
the substance that doesn't biodegrade
it's like teflon right it was that it
was used in teflon started in world war
ii they they synthesized this material
the epa was formed in like the late
1970s and the epa basically just said
they all got grandfathered in so not
being regulated that's the jumping off
point for the movie and i encourage
everyone to see it but at the very least
i would say
read about it just google it um and
it'll give this interview a lot more
context but uh tim was very passionate
about it as he has many other
uh social issues um we talked about
about that and about his film career
and it was just really exciting to to
sit with him i hope you enjoy it i found
it really fascinating talking to him and
i hope you um
get something out of it as well find
value in it my conversation with oscar
winner
and maybe other winners of other things
e's and g's and t's yeah but not a
technical egot but ego definitely an o
yeah oh yeah he's an o he's an eo i
think no he's no okay i think he's no no
tease
whatever you don't know you're not a no
no nothing no cheese judgy
he's an oh that's really impressive i
need to talk to him he's our second o uh
my conversation my c with
tom ribbons also known as tim robbins
six foot five tell tim enjoy
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
i'm already in trouble so
oh no what well let's talk about it
uh this is a perfect place to start
well first of all the thing that strikes
me the most about you and i'm sure you
get this all the time obviously it's
just your
your physical presence is
far more imposing than i had thought
what is that like just i'm always as a
short person i'm always wondering what
is it like to be
six
foot five
to one i mean it's probably hard for you
to say cause you know i i'm able to see
who dyes their hair and who doesn't
yeah
yeah all the roots all the follicles
um
but but as a known person that must
present
obstacles too in terms of
because already people are looking
you're you're such a presence and then
they see that it's you
i wonder what the difference is between
well i i don't really think about it too
much you know there's that moment in
your adolescence when you become tall
really quickly
where
it's a real burden yeah because you're
not comfortable with it and you're kind
of
you know awkward and yeah it's clumsy
and like a labrador puppy yeah and uh
and you get used to that and then um you
start standing up more
uh
straight
uh not as ashamed of your eyes yeah i've
seen tall teenagers they kind of have
kind of slumped over because it's too
new it's too weird you know yeah and you
know particularly with women you know
that are tall
they're made to feel like it's abnormal
but it's fantastic you know well i've
always confounded that women like
wearing high heels and i've been told
it's because they like the way it makes
them stand and the height yeah i don't
understand yeah we probably shouldn't
talk about that we're probably it's
probably it's like mansplaining yeah
high heels yeah to each other
um we were just talking about a dark
dark waters is your new movie it's about
one lawyer's pursuit of the truth and
face in the face of this incredible
environmental disaster that's been
perpetrated by the company dupont for
years it was in the news a couple years
ago it it continues to be in the news it
was today as you
told me um yeah front page of the new
york times yeah the epa
uh is trying to
uh
pass some regulations that would
eliminate
science or the uh studies that have been
done
previously on the connection between
toxins from industry and health
that sounds like a science fiction
headline it's incredible yeah
but it's the natural extension of of uh
an epa that has
deregulated
uh since uh trump took office it's
gotten rid of regulations that protect
us
protect clean air protect clean water
everyone has a right to to to be able to
drink water without fearing that it's
going to be toxic
and
this is a bipartisan issue by the way
well that's the thing water we drink
goes into republican bodies democrat no
matter how you vote yes no matter how
you vote and so it's it's astonishing to
me that there's such a
wanton disregard for the people that
they this administration represents
which is the fact that you have to
preface it by saying this is a
nonpartisan i know that we probably both
have some we bristle people bristle at
this issue and as as it relates to
politics and i wonder how this got
hijacked by
it serves profit margin that's all it
does it just it makes it easier for
chemical companies oil companies anyone
that puts pollutants into our atmosphere
into our environment it makes it easier
for them to make more and more money and
these companies are so massive and they
have the funds to just
keep these issues these uh cases tied up
in court for such a long time that the
movie deals with that in a very in a far
more entertaining way than i would have
thought i mean you think about this
court case that has lasted i mean it
lasts over 12 years 20 years 20 years
now
and and by the way that study that rob
does is a massive study of blood work
people
in the area of where the dupont
plant was 69 000 people i think
participated in this study and i think
it was the most i think was
unprecedented
and it proved a link between
these forever chemicals that dupont
releases into the water
and
cancer
and it was the most extensive study ever
done by the way
this
new epa attempt to eliminate scientific
uh
proof
will affect that as well they'll be able
to throw out the results
of that blood work that took ten years
to do and if you've seen the movie or in
my case have just seen the movie uh that
will really strike you as being
particularly upsetting and absurd uh
when you consider how much work this one
guy did how much he sacrificed to uh to
to bring this to trial this is a real
american hero rob i'm reading his book
right now it's just come out it's it's
uh this is a man that um
you know his his job at his law firm was
to represent chemical companies yeah in
lawsuits against them i taft right he
would work for taft harley which is uh
taft law yeah
out of cincinnati yeah and mark ruffalo
plays this character in the film right
and he was just made a partner uh he's a
hard-working lawyer
and made a partner and the character i
play uh tom turp uh was his uh superior
and uh
rob brought this
case to him and and my character uh tom
said yeah go ahead and then when it
became uh when the when the evidence
started to emerge
um
there was a a movement within the firm
to to like what the hell are we doing
these are the people that you represent
yeah and uh and tom stood up for rob and
uh
uh defended him and and made sure that
this case went forward uh i wanted to
play this role because i
i i believe i have optimism i have hope
there are people in corporate america
that are
moral citizens that do know that when
american business uh acts in such an
egregious way it actually hurts american
business that there should be a moral
bottom line
in when we do business we should be
taking care of our our our consumers
right and your character articulates
that point in the movie did you have any
hand in writing any of that dialogue no
it's just something you responded to
that was why i wanted to do the script
that's why i wanted to do the film
you've said in the past that um
you need to now believe in the i mean
believe in the message of the work that
you're doing uh
when when did that start when when did
you have the luxury of being able to do
things that you just really believed in
after bull durham
wow yeah that's been a while yeah
and um uh it's you know it's listen
i understand uh why uh people do certain
work you know there's mortgages to pay
kids to put through college all that
at some point though you have to make
the decision
how rich you want to be
versus how much you're going to live
your own moral code
and um
there are people that don't this for
this doesn't concern a lot of people you
know that you know it's it's tough to
turn down sure three million dollar
offer
it's tough to you know
not have worked for a while
and to get offers one after the other
for a lot of money for
uh telling stories that i found
offensive and and um to be
propaganda in not serving
the people and
so yeah so it's it it it doesn't make it
easy yeah i know i'm sure um but it it
does uh allow you to sleep a little
better at night yeah and then when you
started making your own movies when you
had full creative control with bob
roberts and and uh dead man walking
was that was that the driving force
behind those movies i mean obviously
they're entertaining and they're well
made films but
was it to
get some message across
well i've always approached um
entertainment as entertainment i
don't believe in
didacticism or propaganda
and so when you know for example when i
was doing dead men walking i felt it was
really essential
to
tell the story of the victims families
with dignity and respect because it's a
tremendous loss that people
have and there's a certain retributive
reaction that comes it's a natural
reaction
to want revenge for your loved one's
death but it in exploring the issue it
you know i felt it was necessary at the
end of that movie to remind the audience
of the murder and um so there were
people in my life at the time that were
saying no you have the audience why why
are you doing that why are you why are
you bringing back the murder
and uh for me it was uh
well if we don't then it's
like a uh
um a temporary solve it's it's it's it's
you you have the audience so but why not
remind them
at the in the last 20 minutes of the
film
and then they can really make the
decision from an informed point of view
and they really can debate because
respect has been paid for to both sides
so i've always approached uh this the
the work that i do not only in in film
but in theater as well
that you you have an obligation to an
audience they have to be uh engaged um
they have to be respected um not
condescended to uh roger eber wrote a
really beautiful review of your movie um
and in it he articulates far better than
i could right now how
the how important it is to make an
audience at times uncomfortable and to
sit with their discomfort and he says uh
yours unlike so many other movies uh
accomplishes that and um i remember
feeling that when i saw that movie for
the first time just when you think
you've made up your mind about this
issue and and how you feel about it it's
you're presented like you said in the
final 20 minutes with the with the full
picture
yes and sister ellen uh after the movie
came out asked me to adapt the
movie into a play
and um i did and we did a reading of it
and there was talk about doing you know
a broadway kind of show and i i didn't
want to do that at the time so what
usually in theater it starts on broadway
it goes to tour then it goes into the
community uh you know and then it goes
into colleges
and so i i decided with that project
let's start in colleges let's let's uh
let's offer the the script to theater
departments across the united states but
in order to get the rights they would
have to involve two other
departments two other disciplines within
the university and they would have to
offer courses on the death penalty and
include sister helen's book dead men
walking in the syllabus and uh i believe
we in the course of 10 years we
reached 280 universities so every time
it was performed there would be
symposiums discussions lecturers uh both
from both sides yeah so that young
people got to engage
in the issue but first engage
emotionally uh in in the theater uh kids
had to play
um people they might not have agreed
with walking and had to walk in those
issues and those shoes and so um
it's been a a really amazing journey
i've seen a few of the productions and
it's it's it's quite amazing what
happens when
uh your
young people are exploring or you'll go
to some of them yes oh wow
you run a theater you started a theater
the actress gang uh in the uh early 80s
i think with um college friends with
people that you went to yeah some punk
rockers from ucla yeah including cusack
right john kizek was i met later he
wasn't at ucla
but uh jack black was he was indicating
the early members of the crew hey you
did a great movie with him high fidelity
um i that's when i i started seeing you
in very different forms i think um uh
playing very different characters and
that was one that i hadn't seen you you
play this really great your age creep
yes new age creep yeah an nac um
you i just want to go back a little bit
you were born in california you raised
in new york uh are your earliest
memories of california or new york were
you new york yeah yeah i think one of my
first memories is on top of the empire
state building really yeah
wow just seeing the expanse of yeah i
mean understand
i was before that in west covina
so the first three years of my life were
relatively quiet yeah and then i got
thrown into this urban those were
formative years though i wonder if that
did anything to your temperament um i
don't know it probably confused me a
little bit
yeah so you identify more as a new
yorker you consider yourself you yeah
from the time i was three to the time i
was 19 i lived in new york uh then i
went to college out at ucla yeah lived
out there for about 10 years then moved
back to new york raised my family
here and then about 10 years 10 years
ago moved back to los angeles did you
play a lot of sports as a kid
i played um
yes i played baseball uh
softball really in manhattan
basketball a little bit yeah mostly
hockey oh that was the sport i loved the
most huh it did and
was the bulldog process was the audition
process that have anything to do with
baseball did you have to oh yeah i had
to be able to throw the ball okay yeah
um i had played third base uh and so i
had a bit of an arm still had to learn
the mechanics of pitching
um
and that was such a that was like one of
those fantasies come true you know you
yeah as a kid you dream of being a
baseball player and then all of a sudden
you're on a set we're in a uniform so
cool it was the best yeah it was a it
was a dream come true and did you know
that that was i mean in addition to that
just the fun
of it did you have any idea that it
would set into motion uh
really the rest of your career that
would be this like kind of a tremendous
change yeah yeah no longer had to
audition yeah
that's a nice change yeah yeah
until uh hudsucker proxy there oh really
ko brothers made me audition which i
appreciated because they had such a
specific vision for it yes and they i i
i
i love that film i love that movie the
tone of it too he has very specific
obviously though i mean the way they're
talking and jennifer jason lee sounds
like she's like right out of the i mean
they all sound like you're you're from
that era yeah rosalind russell yeah
that's great it's the author it's it's
got such a rhythm to it it's such a with
a script like that i'd imagine it's so
tight and i've heard this
of their other scripts certainly big
lebowski that there's no room for i mean
you just really commit to the script
right there oh yeah yeah yeah it was a
it was a lot of fun uh the the biggest
challenge on that film was
learning how to hula hoop
yeah you do a lot of it it took it took
me a while i didn't have a natural uh
in on that oh really that's funny i had
to figure that out it was the biggest
acting challenge in my life
hula hoop and speak at the same time
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
that alone must have been a thrill yeah
i had met him before that but to be able
to spend some good time with him and uh
you know get in a car with him and
you know go get some beer while he's
speeding down the street
because he's maniac oh really and uh he
became a a good friend and a supporter
of the theater company yeah yeah i loved
him i know i know he was also very into
cars he was is that why he was so he
drove like a crazy
crazy really and one i remember one
point thinking if i die
i'm gonna be dying next to a legend
that's gotta go oh that might be all
right yeah you'll be more of a you know
the font on your name in the obituary be
a little smaller
but that'd be all right paul yeah
here's another man that i admired you
know growing up
uh man of principle yes yeah who who
stood by his beliefs and put his money
where his mouth was and
you know i i've been so blessed to
to meet people like that in my career
you know
harry belafonte oh yeah i got to meet
nelson mandela when i was in south
africa wow have lunch with him and
just
incredible
inspirational people that have come into
my life some famous some not yeah yeah
um you know i was remember being in a
bar in northern ireland
the first night i was there and these
guys come up to me and they said you
know hey you tim robbins i said yeah
they said we're gonna take care of you
while you're here huh i was like wow uh
in new orleans no this was in northern
ireland oh in northern ohio but uh
what did that do that seems a little
almost ominous it was a little ominous
but i you know at the same time i was
like you know well
i i get what that where they're coming
from it it there's you know the same
thing happened to me in south africa uh
oh sure uh some former anc members came
up to me and
wow you know said we got your back
it's it's uh
there is a uh
there's a community of people in the
world that um
uh whose voices aren't heard
and um i i try whenever i can to um
to uh use my platform to
speak for the poor for the marginalized
for the indigenous that are
struggling against uh power yeah and i
think that's probably something that's
attracted both of us to bernie sanders i
know that you uh were active in his
campaign you
gave some speeches uh on his behalf in
2016. and and it's sort of what's behind
your current movie the movie we've been
talking about dark waters um and now
that i think about it it's
a lot of your great work has has that
thread throughout it um dead man walking
to you directed a lot of treme episodes
um and i read that that was after you
spent some time in new orleans uh
shooting
uh mr grip no no no no i was down there
with the one of the movies that i
had to do for
and pay the mortgage but green uh green
lantern uh lane lantern lantern yeah
yeah yes one of the greens
here's a here it was a kind of
interesting phone call with the agent
they were like um well they want you to
do this thing it's pretty good money uh
and uh
but it's over a course of like four
months
and so they are saying they'll fly you
in and out of los angeles right
and i was going through a period of my
life that i was in a bit of a transition
and i said you know what i'm going to
get an apartment down there
and i'm going to live down there for
four months awesome and first thing i
did when i got there is i got a bicycle
bought a bicycle
and i i just started to
discover that beautiful city that is
just a remarkable place i love it so
much and i've been there before katrina
and i've been many times and worked many
times there since katrina um and i know
you were so inspired by it and the
people that you in fact i think i've
read that you called up the creator of
treme uh david simon yeah and and said
you know if you need me if you need my
services and obviously he probably
jumped at that because you're such a
pleasure to work with him and and that
whole crew down there and the cast was
so great steve zahn is one of my
favorites amazing yeah
uh and so when you were doing green
lantern you said i'm not gonna fly back
and forth i'm just gonna really immerse
myself in this culture culture it's an
entirely different culture so i learned
so much about uh
that about music
yeah uh about
congo square which is really where
american music started did you play down
there no it was more just
listening to people uh tell their own
story tell their own history
the whole uh indians uh movement down
there uh the the
but the would that be creole
well
so what happened was uh
because it was a french colony
um the french unlike the english
gave
their slaves one day a week to be on
their own to two to one day of freedom a
week
so what would happen was a lot of the
slaves would meet in congress square
which was right outside of where uh the
houses were in new orleans and
in congo square
they carried on the traditions
the musical traditions of their
countries
and this mixed with the seminal indian
culture
and so the combination of those two
cultures
created
what we know is rock and roll
the indian beat is the bow diddly beak
and so uh
i the to hear them tell it uh the the
the
the it was like the genesis of american
music and what happened was it traveled
up the mississippi yeah to memphis to st
louis to chicago um
in terms of speaking on behalf of of
marginalized people uh
do you ever find it to be insurmountable
how do you do you ever have moments
where you feel like
hopeless nihilistic like
you know it's constantly inspired by
uh what i see uh in chile recently oh
yeah two million people going out on the
street
protesting against the government that
had responded to their protests with the
by calling up the military and killing
people
two million people out there really
inspiring still out there still
protesting
i stand with the people i stand with the
poor i stand with the indigenous i stand
with
people that don't have power and um
for people uh
in my business that's not easy to do
it's not encouraged do you think it's
cost you jobs
um i've been asked that question enough
to
believe that it might yeah um
well
one more add one more to the pie let me
just say that since i won the oscar i
haven't been offered a lead role in a
major studio production
i've worked for independent films i've
i've been able to work so you know it's
very um i'm very reluctant to complain
because i'm no i would i feel very uh
lucky sure benefici bet to benefited
from uh the the entertainment industry
um they're in this country there are
as far as i'm concerned in my experience
been no gulags there's been no you know
mass arrests
but other people without uh access uh
have a probably a larger struggle than i
do well you know that's what struck me
as as
extra noble about what rob uh is doing
in the movie what rob's blot
is continuing to do is that he is
amplifying the voices of these people
that have been marginalized for
generations and were not for somebody
like him who had access to power who was
himself powerful
their voices would continue to fall on
deaf ears and and
and that no better example of that than
in flint michigan i mean there's no no
action no real action has been taken in
flint um
that's when i begin to lose hope you
know um that that it could be such a
huge headline for so long
part of the national conversation and
nothing gets done about it do you think
that is all about electing the right
officials
is it all about who we get in positions
of power
no as bernie says it's about
us it's a it's it's not about electing
him it's about a movement that has to
be
not only
uh
elected into office but maintained it
it's it's uh harry belafoni once said to
me the reason they call it a struggle is
because it's it you don't you don't you
can't expect to win
you know you have to know that the work
continues that there will always be
forces that are stronger than you that
are trying to
roll back the progress that you may have
achieved um and they're still doing it
today so you know it's um
i i have faith in people i have faith in
art
art will survive
just recently in chile we were down
there in january with this play called
the new colossus that i developed with
my theater company actors gang and it
tells the story of immigration it tells
us it's 12 actors telling
their own um ancestors stories of what's
called a journey from oppression to
freedom
uh 12 different time periods from 1868
to the present
12 different languages spoken in the
play
and at the end of the play we engage the
audience and we ask you know
where are you from and we have these
amazing um experiences with our
audiences and you know i ask uh first
how many people here uh
are indigenous to this country and and
then i asked how many uh were
descended from people that were brought
here against their will
and african americans you know raised
their hand do you know where from and
here's the tragedy most of them don't
and then i ask how many are immigrants
or refugees and some hands come up and i
ask from where and what year
then sons are daughters of immigrants or
refugees more hands come up grandsons
granddaughters of immigrants or refugees
more hands come up great grandsons etc
until everybody in the audience has
raised their hand and we realize we are
part of a larger community
and we did this in chile and at the end
of the
play we we played this song called el
dorecho de vivian en pass a spanish song
by this
folk singer named victor hara and viktor
hara was
very popular in chile and was one of the
people that was killed in the coup
d'etat
when they overthrew allende's government
pinochet yeah and um i met his widow
and his daughter when i was down there
and um
i uh it was such an honor to meet them
and his music was so beautiful and so
moving and he had such respect for
the the culture of chile and and the
music of chile at a time when chile was
being fed american rock and roll he was
reminding chileans of their own culture
and so uh recently i was seeing one of
the the
tweets that came out of the protests
and there uh i i i'm witnessing 10 000
people uh um at a rally and uh 30 guys
with guitars singing
uh el doracho de vivre impaza song
written in 1970 that everyone knew the
words that's really cool and that just
it just made me believe in
the the power of art yeah you know and
the people and the people
that they have these stories that they
will continue to tell now i feel silly
having asked you do you do you lose
faith that's must really affirm your
faith in the power of i experience it
because i because i'm doing theater
because i see
what we do in theater that's so unique
is that we're able to
assemble a community a temporary
community for the night
people from all over
people with different points of view and
they sit in a dark room and we're able
to go on a journey with them at the end
of which
we
you know they have experienced laughter
sadness they've experienced emotion
together it unifies them in a way that's
so unique and so special it's one of the
last places on earth that we can ask a
group of people please turn off your
cell phones right now and they'll
actually do it yeah and they'll be able
to go to a reflective place yeah and
develop for this temporary moment a
community so that they can feel they're
not alone right yeah it's so essential
it's really beautiful i thought
why is it that it's been so long since
you've made a movie your movies are all
all three of them are
incredible and uh
and you seem still so active in the arts
you mean as a director as a director um
well uh how insulting would that have
been if i had been like well after i
made cradle of rock in 99 um
my son was uh seven years old
and he said daddy i like it better when
you act
and i took that i mean
no i took it to mean that i was there
more for yeah yeah and i stopped working
for a while after that and uh acting and
everything and just wanted to get to
know this
this incredible
human being that makes sense and um
and so i i started
getting my jones out by directing
theater
after that uh um because there's a lot
shorter but time commitment less
obsession you know when i direct the
film i'm pretty obsessed you have to i
think what he was saying was you check
out completely
and um
so i started getting interested in doing
it again uh when he went to college
uh the environment had changed in
hollywood um there wasn't as much
appetite for the kinds of films i wanted
to make
i have written a couple of scripts that
i believe would be
really great
i'm
having a little difficulty finding the
money to do them
and so uh i'm willing to do it i'm i'm
ready to do that and if any listeners
out there have 15 million dollars and
want to produce a film um most of our
listeners are billionaires or at least
multi-millionaires uh
i wish i did because i i i would look
forward to i just finished a script that
i wrote for
my own sanity
uh which is a satire on what is
happening right now
and just to process everything yeah and
i'm having a great time doing it i'm
making myself laugh
that's a good sign
but
it's like how do you satirize a satire
yeah you know yeah that's the thing it's
the news seems satirical yeah and so
it's it gets crazy it's it's a it's a
incredibly twisted script and uh
who knows we'll see maybe some twisted
millionaire out there will give me some
money i hope so god any twisted
millionaires listening uh it'd be cool
if we had a twisted millionaire
listening to this show uh i have to ask
you about shawshank i'm sure everyone
does is that is this that the movie that
when people see you on the street
they'll quote or they'll say it depends
on where i am right uh i get bull durham
whenever i'm around a sporting event for
sure i get jacob's ladder a lot i guess
we're gonna lose a lot
and yes shawshank um when you're around
martin lawrence you get nothing to lose
yeah
uh i get it
all over the place oh really okay
um
but you know shawshank has this special
quality to it the people that
speak to me about it
need to tell me
uh that it affected them
that it changed them in some way i i
feel incredibly blessed to be part of a
a film like that because that's kind of
what we dream
when we enter this field you know that
we can make something that resonates for
so many years
and um
when um that came out it didn't make a
lot of money it wasn't considered a
success really
what i came to understand is what makes
a movie successful
isn't necessarily its initial box office
it's whether the movie can be seen in 10
years and
still works that's whether it can still
be seen in 20 years and still work and i
i feel really proud to have been part of
quite a few of those kinds of movies
that still work and still resonate and
you know
i don't care really about
what the box office is i want to know if
it's going to last in whether the
because what lasts
is what resonates with people yeah you
worry about alienating your fan base and
and
potentially you know you've mentioned
how it may have hurt your career and uh
or i said that and you you tacitly
agreed in a way that uh
semi agreed yeah sometimes because you
have to understand something career and
life are the same thing to someone you
know you can't separate your life from
your career yeah and if you make
concessions
you know to serve your career it might
not necessarily serve your life right
and so you might be wind up being a lot
richer
but
what does that mean
for your soul and for who you are and
what you and what you were like you said
if you walked away from what you were
to serve your economic bottom line
that's
not a place i was ever comfortable uh
working towards you still enjoy doing
you still love yeah but i've been
blessed to have the actors gang because
when when um
things weren't being more incoming to me
i would still have a a place to work and
to to create new work and experiments
it's like a laboratory that's really
cool it kept me excited and
involved and creative and writing and
directing and was that what compelled
you to start that in the first place
just the idea of of having your own
space to create your own things well we
started it as a kind of a rebellion
against the the the you know the
what what was being done at the theater
department and
yeah yeah we wanted to make more punk
rock kind of thing well they were doing
just kind of mainstream yeah but it was
a great theater department and it
allowed for us to exist which was great
and it gave us space to exist
and gave us space to to develop our
talents and a lot of really good people
came out of there and did you see right
away that the the industry was uh not
necessarily
interested in promoting
the arts and a creative
mentality at the time i came into it
there were a lot of those people they
were still
out of the 70s and you know
these rogue filmmakers that really
wanted to tell new kinds of stories so i
came up with that and i got inspired by
that i loved it you know i got to work
with robert altman three times oh that's
right of course i got to you know learn
much from from him yeah and you know and
his uh approach to filmmaking and i was
so lucky to work on the player right
before i directed my first film
right i was like film school for me i
got to you know
you know be a collaborator with robert
altman what was he like did he just
shoot a ton of stuff was he just no he
was
he was free
that's what i loved about it yeah he was
free to create and he knew that
proper environment for creation
is freedom and what i you know i'm
sitting there in pre-production with him
we're you know working on the script and
and uh people are coming into his office
all the time saying bob what about this
what about this you know various
department heads and props costumes
and i remember very clearly him saying
when asked questions he said uh i don't
know what do you think yeah
and i knew he knew uh-huh uh but he i
just wanted perspectives he wanted well
the way he explained it to me was why
would i cheat myself of someone else's
opinion but yeah it's true and it was
that humility yes to be able to
understand that
it's actually a burden
to think of yourself as
the leader or authority
yeah because it it limits uh the
collaborative process totally and i
learned that from altman and the idea
that it was a it was a big yes and
you know i knew that he knew
what the answers were to be able to be
in the room with him
and to be
invited into the process
of
you know rewriting the script
uh
that with him yes wow that he
trusted me and that he valued me and i
remember in my first meeting with him he
talked about
what what it was that
he liked about oh yeah what i'm curiou
yeah he said the theater you're doing oh
huh the actor's gay oh wow had he seen a
production there or uh i believe he had
but beyond that he had also been through
that journey himself where he wasn't
being allowed to make films but at this
so he what he would do is he would find
plays and then he filmed them so he did
secret honor that way and come back to
the five and dime jimmy dean
and you know in that period even
asheville a lot of kind of estranged
from hollywood for a while oh
interesting a lot of his movies feel i
mean a lot of his shots are set up
they're just wide i mean there's scenes
that are played out in just these yeah
great wide shots and and as a director
he gives you freedom as an actor to
create you know absolutely yeah this is
the script but you know if you have
something better just
that's so great and you weren't
intimidated i mean also to not be
intimidated around a guy like that well
because he wouldn't allow it yeah and
that's what a you know great director he
was discovery happens from the unknown
yeah and the
the
worst thing you could
do as an actor is be overly confident
and say i got this
and
limit the discovery
of the unknown yeah wow and so so uh
like like life is that way yeah you know
what i mean sure when we're walking down
the street we don't know what's going to
happen
we are living in the unknown all the
time and we all in the course of our day
improvise our life right of course and
so when you're trying to recreate
reality on the stage or in film
it's it's a it's a it's a difficult
place to be in but it's a for me it's
been a very productive place to be in to
to live in the unknown to not be decided
to don't ever be the expert yeah when no
one
can anticipate
the surprises that might happen in the
course of a day how do you make god
laugh tell them what you're doing
tomorrow yeah you know yeah that's great
life could be a dream
[Music]
alan rickman's talking about he was a
really important person in my love and i
he's talking about acting and he said
you know he was confounded by the idea
that actors should learn these
monologues and rehearse them in the
mirror and he's like oh you ha i can't
do an impression but all you have to do
is just sit and be present yes you know
and listen
and he was an angel he was in my life
you know yeah he's the reason bob
roberts happened no kidding yeah i was
in pre-production in pittsburgh
pennsylvania uh i thought the money was
coming through and then the rules got
changed and i needed another star in the
movie and so i was desperately you know
trying to find somebody who were like
like three weeks away from shooting
and um
got the script to allen and he was
riding high off the die hard thing yeah
and uh he read the script and loved it
it wasn't a particularly showy role
uh but he saw the value of the project
and signed on and saved my ass next up
what is next dark waters is out now oh
and you and you're in castle rock
castle rock yeah on hulu it's crazy it's
cool it's it's the stephen king universe
yeah which is amazing that he's so
prolific that he now has his own
universe yeah
but it's so twisted yeah and every week
there's a new twisted thing that happens
i just love it it's just
there's some very twisted people writing
for that show and did they revis does he
have a hand in the writing uh steaming
no not at all he he lets all these
projects go he stays stays up in maine
and he writes his own stuff in portland
yeah um but yeah i have uh this on hulu
and uh
got the new colossus tour coming up oh
so you toured around the states yeah
cool all all across the united states uh
starting at the end of january
uh i think we're hitting 10
10 11 cities
um and i'll be going out on the road
with that cool what is your most
commonly used emoji
i can't believe i'm asking you this i
don't really use emoji that's what i
figured yeah that was a trick question
and you and it has never you've never
used one i might have a couple of times
okay
i'm still the you know you can say what
kind of still the colon parentheses
emojis that's fine all right the colon
being the apparent the grammar cohen
yeah not like the the emoji of a colon
which i don't think they have yet no
they got to develop that though yeah
well that's something we can also how do
you tell the difference between a colon
and a liver and emoji uh it's got to be
good artwork right it's a good question
yeah i hope hopefully they're working on
that
um if you could be i think i know this
one but if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
oh well i'd say hockey actually oh yeah
i love rangers fan right yeah huge
rangers fan do you go to games i
whenever i'm in town i go to games um i
actually was at the game when they won
the stanley cup oh nice and i got i was
with my college uh roommate
and uh
we got in a cab and we said
at the after the game i didn't have any
ins with the with the team at the time
and so we got in the cab and we said
take us to the cup
went to the cab driver yeah and we went
downtown we thought it was there for a
while and
the place was dead and so we went uptown
and the guy drove around for like an
hour and couldn't find it and then we
got into another cab and said take us to
the cup he goes oh i know where it is
and he took us to this place on the east
side no [ __ ] and uh we were in our
ranger jerseys and uh it was a pretty
fancy party and uh got to the stanchion
and i'm waiting to get through the
stanchion
with everyone out you're the first time
in my life
wanting to be recognized
and shushing
any different and the cops let me
through and then i got to the door and
and the guy goes uh
no you can't come in here you have the
jersey on this is a classy place right
oh does he so does he recognize you or
no no he didn't but the other guy that
was at the door said wait a minute
that guy was wearing the ranger blue in
vancouver because i had flown out for
game six that's balls and i wore the
blue out there you're one of those guys
stop throwing it out and heads got beat
up and they won that game and i you know
wound up going back to new york for game
seven oh so you're like a hardcore
fighter oh yeah oh and so
that guy let it let me in
because he recognized you from
everything from being on television well
it is pretty admirable yeah and then we
drank from the cup that night that's
really cool and did were the two members
of the team there did they yeah
messier came in a half hour later with
the cop that's so they must know and you
i mean
and then yeah and then we
drank it it was like six in the morning
and the new york police department
bagpipe band was playing and
that's
surreal that's really so awesome that's
really cool uh what's your favorite
movie of all time
oh i'd have to say uh it's a wonderful
life ah
i can watch that movie and cry anytime
you've played jimmy stewart s
parts i i can see that from your mouth
to god's ears yeah no what an amazing
actor yeah yeah and i always used to
keep a picture of him in my office
because i wanted to remind myself of
what a great actor he was
and also that he was a republican you
know and that i i wanted to remind
myself that
once
the way one leans politically does not
necessarily
mean that they aren't a great artist
yeah oh that's good well i mean although
republicanism was a lot different than
it was no that's for sure she wasn't
like a dixie grand no no but what a
beautiful actor yeah
yeah um i like that uh if you could have
one snack food for the rest of your life
let's say
not that you do but if you were to smoke
and you got the munchies and you wanna i
do okay good i'm not ashamed
okay i don't know why i
tiptoed around that um so when you're
stoned uh what's your go-to actually it
doesn't make this weird i don't i i
never get hungry when i'm stoned
really i get super interested in doing
creative stuff
i do too but there's all there's no
appetite not at all wow not at all
you're lucky but when i'm not stoned my
go-to is uh
popcorn oh okay i like popcorn okay just
straight up the movie style yeah none of
that cheese flavor is
chemicals
okay
uh
if you had to live somewhere else where
would it be oh uh
hmm
yeah um i mean
i like italy a lot
i love new orleans
i would i could live there i could live
in italy
uh the italians have figured something
out yeah you know something about life
that
is lasting and you know i spent a lot of
time over there in the past five years
and
just love the people i love the culture
i love it yeah
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met and you've had some dinner with
already people have said nelson mandela
but you actually got to have dinner with
him i'd like to hang out with charlie
chaplin oh yeah
um who else uh you know
be cool to hang out with mozart
uh
i'm not sure bertolt breck would be a
lot of laughs but well you have to
get his perspective yeah you know you
already have a lot of laughs with
chaplin and and probably mozart yeah he
seemed like a fun
wild time um
breath moon starting chaplain it's a
good dinner who's your favorite muppet
of the muppets well i got to work with
elmo
well now you're just name-dropping yeah
now i'm just damned
i did a few scenes with uh
prairie don was that her yeah yeah i did
a musical with her really yeah called
the four seasons we i just got to sing
with prairie dog that's awesome and i'm
sure people can youtube that she was
awesome yeah she's good to work she
won't hang out with me anymore though
yeah yeah
um if you have a superpower what would
it be
um
well i would
yeah this is funny because like we uh um
yeah um oh don't censor yourself no
it's just you know like we
like at the at the gang at the actors
gang like come up with ridiculous super
powers yeah yeah
like completely useless right i would
have
i would have hair that never grew
yeah
i can turn cotton into dust
my armpits would never smell
i guess that'd be all right it would be
great to fly yeah oh yeah yeah um uh
beetles or stones beetles not that i
don't love the stones but the beetles
sir come on yeah and change the world
have you seen the movie yesterday
i i yeah oh no we're not into it i i i
you know i was
weeping mess on the plane yesterday so
that happens on planes even maybe movies
i i i find myself a weeping mess on on
planes i had such an emotional reaction
oh that's cool yeah i wonder if it's
because you're
there's such a fine line between your
life and death yeah you're really
i mean a romantic comedy will make me
weep
on a plane that's interesting yeah well
you're so vulnerable because you're yeah
maybe because your life is in the hands
of yeah maybe a little drunk too
it's just like what was my life
that doesn't hurt the emotions um do you
think about uh your epitaph or or legacy
or how you want to go out uh be
remembered no no i'm gonna live forever
oh okay oh that's that's kind of a
superpower i should have you should have
mentioned your answer for that yeah um
and it doesn't bother you you don't
dwell on it you don't worry about
no
i feel really uh
blessed uh to have
had the experiences i've had in life i
feel like uh i'm not done and i feel
like i want to
you know i've been working on a memoir
and i feel
like i would love for certain things
i've done
to
uh
be out there
i've written quite a few plays
that
i i think i will
make available soon on my website
what is the website tim
it's tim robbins.net
you know i i don't tend to to think that
way uh yeah you know it's depressing
you're depressed to me sorry
you know well remember the rangers uh
one there's the cub remember that moment
you're trying to distract me now let's
go back to that
no no it's funny because when you get to
like i turn 60 uh last year yeah and um
that was weird i bet you know because i
don't feel 60 at all i feel like i could
you know
and i have really great energy you don't
i was going to say you don't have the
energy of it of a 60 year old oh no i
feel really great yeah i feel like 58.
i feel at least 57 yeah yeah but
so i don't think in terms of you know
the end it i just don't yeah well but in
10 years i'll probably have some good
stuff for you okay we'll come here i
want to be remembered you'll be still
here's my appetite okay you have it all
planned out um
i so appreciate what you're doing for um
for the world i mean and for our country
and i hope people see dark waters and uh
and i'm looking forward to seeing your
play uh with the name of it one more
time the new colossus the new colossus
goes on tour january the end of january
you can check the actors gang website
the elector's gang the actors gang.com
and we'll have an updated list okay all
right we'll do that and uh
watch dark waters and castle rock on
hulu and re-watch
all of them jacob's lighter bull durham
uh incredible rock incredible rock sea
crater will rock please yeah that's the
one i'm most proud of thank you so much
my pleasure
so
well
anyways that happens
that happened i
can i just start yeah by saying that
how did you not do your morgan freeman
impressions i know i i was talking to
andy dufrey i thought about it i thought
about it i
i thought about it what a missed
opportunity
you've done that impression so many
times on this show i know you did you
think you thought about doing it yes i
did
i sure did or was he he was just too
into he's intimidating yeah first of all
he's huge and he doesn't give
up much and i don't mean this that's not
an insult if anything that's kind of
like i admire that i i think i give too
much um
in terms of first impressions hey you
know
um
he just didn't seem to be interested in
like
letting people know that he was
excited to be there it's funny you told
me that afterwards i wasn't there and
and
i was expecting it my expectations were
oh this might be a little tough to
listen to mm-hmm uh because they maybe
didn't connect as well as
as they could have but i didn't get that
at all oh good i didn't that didn't
translate oh that's good now i'm i
thought it was super interesting oh
that's good i'm really regretting now
not doing morgan free because you're
right how many chances will i have to
that might have been the only chance you
ever get i know
andy dufresne was my friend no too late
don't do it now to me well maybe he's
literally i don't want to hear it
he's not listening you know i don't
think so
maybe uh i doubt it he is so articulate
he's got such more he's got more
important things to do he is such a
smart human being well that's belittling
to the people who are listening who to
suggest
the shorties
to say that like oh tim robbins has
better things to do than listen to i
would say better things i did i'm
calling myself oh yeah uh i don't think
he's better things he might be listening
i think he
missed
andy dufrese
i think it's different when you're the
guest on the show
you've already heard the conversation
you were part of the conversation yeah
that's true so i always assume that
people who are on the show don't that's
true in fact i've done i've been on
podcasts i don't listen to afterwards i
don't think i would listen if i was on a
podcast kind of i'm really what a what a
missed opportunity yeah that's all right
uh maybe i can do my tim robin's
impression if morgan freeman comes up
oh my god
uh he's tough to do with tim robinson
can you do one
i don't think i can he talks like he's
in a library did you notice that
everything everything is sort of hushed
and respected well but thoughtful
he give he he really
he's a great listener
yeah did you notice that he waited every
time you asked him a question and i
think this may have intimidated you a
little bit because sometimes i stumbled
a lot you stumbled near the end of the
question because he wasn't talking but
it was only i think it was only because
he
is the kind of person who
waits until yeah the entire question is
over because he needs to think about it
he wanted to absorb my whole thought
exactly and i'm
sometimes i abandoned the thought
because i felt like oh it's he
thinks it's not too smart enough exactly
because he is really intelligent he is
he's very bright he's intimidatingly
bright and he's six foot five so he's
intimidatingly big that yeah that's a
combination it is
and he's measured you know which is also
intimidating when somebody is
very
you know they're they're deliberate in
how they are right and how he listens
and
that can really throw off a little
monkey like
uh i'd like but i think you did a
good job of not but i could tell you
were a little intimidating especially in
the beginning and you would rush your
questions a little bit um because he
wasn't jumping in right i think it was
only and i think you maybe misread him
not jumping in for
him he's kind of not wanting to be there
or he wasn't he definitely wasn't yeah
but i think he's just thoughtful yeah
it definitely wasn't the funniest
interview i've ever heard uh but you
know what i regret sorry to interrupt
not asking him about about shawshank
i regret i was really curious about that
one shot where it's an iconic shot the
aerial overhead shot in the rain where
he's like
ah he like kind of like goes down to his
knees and looks up at the sky i was
really curious about
how they did that and like what was
going on if he felt a little if there
were any moments where he felt like
often silly or awkward yeah yeah
he he probably would have said no
i'm sure i didn't feel that that's
probably why i didn't ask
uh but it was funny when he said you
were talking about his height and he
said you're like what what's that like
what's that yeah and he said uh it's
easy for him to see when people dye
their hair that was funny it's funny
yeah it's funny and i would i would i
would like that power too i've noticed i
think i have that power a little bit
yeah
i think we both are good at well because
our mother was very aware of things like
that when we were growing up um i was
just in fort lauderdale and you know
you see
more elderly people down there and i
mean like
really old like really old people with
this like
jet blast there yeah like auburn there's
a lot more of that i've noticed yeah me
too um he also doesn't understand high
heels you don't so that was another
thing you had in common
both of you were like yeah i don't get
that and we have a lot of female
listeners listening right now who are
rolling their eyes or i know i don't
mean
it's
i i also have attempted to wear them i
tried to wear them in the breakup my
character wears heels and
some of those scenes had to be
it was such a relief when they changed
the blocking to me sitting down i ended
up sitting down for a lot of that but
there was some of that where i had to
get up and walk away like um
and and it was really difficult for me
to do i actually like admire it i i
for people who can do physically i think
it's an admirable thing to be able to do
but you know why why they're worn right
it's it's something that happens to the
leg they like the look of the legs in
the interview you said that they like
being taller which i don't i mean maybe
that's part of it but i think i think
i'm wrong about it uh
listeners correct me if i'm wrong but i
i think it has more to do
with what it does to the leg itself like
what it does to the shape of the leg oh
i didn't say that i don't think so i
think you just said it makes women
taller yeah i've heard that from women
that they like
the [ __ ] it makes the calf muscle more
like defined or something which is fine
which is good
but
where i think it becomes silly is when
if someone can't walk in them
and they're teeter-tottering down the
road
at that point it doesn't matter what the
shape of their leg is
notice their awkwardness is how awkward
they're walking yeah um i like how
you were talking about the environment
and he
i think he mentioned or you mentioned
that it
uh should be a non-partisan issue which
it's
not yeah
he talks about the difference between
being rich
versus living your moral code
and it
it does seem like he's been able to
accomplish both a business career and
he's done certain jobs that are
more for money but i think for the most
part he
it seems like he takes on projects that
he believes in yeah that's fine but like
how does he
justify or
um
[Music]
how does he
live with this a dramatic way to say it
how does he internalize the jobs like
green lantern he talks about green
lantern well i think he would justify it
by saying
that he has a mortgage to pay and and
you know children to raise and yeah he
needs to make money yeah i guess so he
seems very earnest about the things he
believes in though he definitely does
not seem like lip service to me no no he
talks about uh he at one point i thought
it was interesting that he said
life and career are the same thing yeah
so that yeah you shouldn't make career
concessions because those become life
concessions
but again i mean like but he made
something he did concessions yeah and
which is totally fine like
i i i don't think he's any less
convicted about these other things you
know about these strong beliefs that he
has i liked what he said about living in
new orleans for four months it was a
very life is short kind of thing yeah
how he
uh instead of flying back and forth when
he was there he really committed to
ingratiating himself in the city he got
a bicycle when he got there and he said
uh
he said
he listened a lot and in new orleans is
obviously one of the best cities in the
country for listening in general um oh
my god but
it struck me that
that uh
his
desire to listen
in new orleans
is such a good example of
why he's a good artist because in order
to create anything great you need to be
able to absorb so much
stuff around you and i think he's
excellent at absorbing the world that's
what we started i mean now we're full
circle we started talking about that
he's a really good listener and he takes
things in very he internalizes in a very
deliberate way yes i i it made me think
back to a lot of jobs i've had on
location in new orleans i mean like we
both have we both did a movie in new
orleans that was like not the best movie
but so such great memories of being
there and
um
i i love that about jobs about out of
town jobs where especially if you have a
smaller part like we were talking to
judy greer about how she said
the sweet spot on a call sheet is number
three to number seven
and i'm sure tim on that movie was
probably like you know four or five yeah
you have some you have a bunch of days
off and then you go in and work have fun
and
and you got like three days in a row you
just tool around new orleans on a bike
it's more impressive to me
with a guy like that because he's
incredibly intelligent and the things he
says you you know he's confident in
so for him to be that willing to listen
to others
i think is impressive because he he he's
the kind of person who has so much to
say and to teach people well but yet he
yeah he has a lot to say he's so willing
to be a student
that's cool
which which also goes back to the
theater that he does and how he performs
it for students and loves listening to
the talkbacks and people's reactions and
i think he's a true like
i i i don't often think of
actors as artists and i know that's
wrong of me i just don't
there's something like the visual arts
to me are
you know i get like sculpting and
painting and those but when i think of
acting as as like an artistic venture i
but he seems like a true artist well he
was talking a lot about theater at the
end and
so often i find people who talk about
theater in that way
um i i find them to be so pretentious
and obnoxious
they talk about the theater as being
this life-changing
important thing for the world and and i
i i know it ends up rubbing me the wrong
way more often than not but there's
something about the way he was talking
about it in terms of unifying people and
bringing people from all different walks
of life together in one space and having
the shared moment i i it was just
something about the way he was talking
about it that i really
locked into and i agreed with him and i
i often do not well like talking about
either theater i don't either i mean
i've heard people talk about the theater
and and sometimes like you know
sometimes theater actors will talk about
theater like it's so much loftier and
more important than any other form of
acting and movies are kind of like for
you know commercial values
pet yeah and and they talk about in this
way and really at the heart of it it's
like yeah but you would do a movie yeah
you would jump at the chance to do a
movie and like there's something about
tim robbins having experience in both
in both fields where like i
i i there's more merit to what to when
he talks about theater and the important
stuff it's not because he's not getting
movie exactly exactly it's because he
genuinely respects the theater and feels
at home there
and he's writing plays i know he's just
so prolific i know and he values
people's the audience's reaction and
when he talks about making audiences
engaged like engaging audiences i really
believe that's important to him having
said that i think
someone should give him 15 million
dollars to direct a movie i know because
he's a really good director how you know
did it give chris and i have been trying
to make this feature and it looks like
we're going to make it i hope uh maybe i
just jinxed us but um it's maybe youtube
it's it's been you know it's the
everyone says how difficult it is but
like
hearing that he is having a hard time
making a movie uh getting money raising
money to make a movie it made me um i
made me feel a little bit better about
the struggles in that capacity that
we've had but
how could he not get
act like sean penny he knows so many
actors i know so many famous it doesn't
make sense to me i know any and his
track record is like you know i had
never seen the third movie he directed
the one that he told everyone will rock
crater will rock i haven't seen it
either i mean i feel like we should
watch it okay okay maybe we should have
watched it before this
uh finally i
was very surprised
when he didn't want to talk about death
and
uh oh yeah and and his legacy and
um
i was really surprised but just only
because it it didn't seem on brand i
know with with what he had been talking
about he seems like the kind of person
who
would uh really relish an opportunity to
talk about his mortality and his legacy
or would it seem
superficial and not and self-indulgent
maybe because it's not about something
that will affect people
the world and people and you know
maybe that's a very optimistic spin well
also he seems like a he seems like he
genuinely cares about marginalized
people and the injustices that are done
to them
and right and his death or his legacy
that has nothing to do with um
it's also like but there seemed to be a
fearful element to it yeah you're right
i don't want to talk about it right
you're depressing i think you said
yeah means everything he's not like a
sarcastic guy no but but again it's
weird he doesn't seem like the kind of
guy who would say oh i don't think about
death i would depress me he just seemed
like you were saying he lives this
uh
ultra internal life yeah he just seems
like such a thoughtful kind of mistake
almost yeah yeah and that type of person
to me
is a person who thinks about their own
mortality quite a bit i was shocked by
that well maybe and a lot of actors are
like this i'm certainly like this where
because we get to as kevin smith says
make pretend for a living and play and
go from these one job to the next
there's no real structure
to to a career like that to a life like
that
maybe you just kind of lose track of
time maybe he's
an example of that in fact when he said
he's like i don't feel like i'm 61 he's
he's like i'm 61 and he's like i just
don't feel that way i he he was kind of
articulating how i think i might feel
when i'm his age if i get to be his age
you know i should be a lot shorter
yeah
yeah a lot and let and less pensive much
less pensive it's funny that you tiptoe
around him smoking pot at the end you
were like i don't know if you ever
indulged of course he does now he was
like yeah i'm very comfortable with him
he's like known isn't he known for being
like an old hippie i think so
you want to read a letter yeah it's the
second one
this is from melanie a
subject hello
hi justin and christian i'm a big fan of
the podcast never miss an episode
uh felt compelled to write in after
hearing about justin's child oh
childhood anger issues around monopoly
as i totally relate oh thanks melanie i
too was a competitive child with poor
control of my anger to the point where i
was banned from playing any board games
with my siblings because every time i
was losing i would pick up the whole
board and throw it across the room well
it's worse than you oh my god
well i'm like judging her now she's
trying to commiserate i'm like jesus
melanie
um i'm delighted to say i'm now a
relatively kind and well-rounded adult
person so justin rest assured your dark
past makes you no less attractive to me
haha ah i hope that was not sarcastic
you're not attractive
um i also wanted to share how i
quote cockatin bullets because
because life is short i'm 35 and work in
a sensible job in hr at a bank but i
felt for some time that something was
missing and have recently started
studying dance teaching
studying dance teaching and seriously
taking ballet again after almost 20
years wow it's cool i don't know if i'll
end up as a ballet teacher or how it
will work out but i'm enjoying the
journey i've been so much happier and i
don't want to get to 80 and wonder if i
could have ever been a ballet teacher if
i tried so there it is life is short let
go of the i can't and do what makes your
heart sing that is really cool
uh lots of love oh
[ __ ] i read it wrong lots of love
melanie from australia oh sorry man you
want to read the whole thing again no
i'm just kidding please just please
definitely i'm a big fan of the podcast
oh god that's more that now i hear the
new zealand podcast i just spent a few
days with rada mitchell who's an
australian actress and i um
she
she helped me a little bit with the
accent but she said it wasn't bad she
was really giving me i'm not saying it's
bad i just don't know i never read the
whole letter i'm speaking to some of the
shorties out there who were hating on it
um that's really sweet thank you melanie
and that's i hope again someone trying
something new or trying or or being
active yeah and the important thing that
she wrote is that you know what whatever
it leads to it's not like it doesn't
matter
it'd be fun to take a dance class
salsa or something no please take a
ballet class why don't don't you have to
do a ballet class yeah i don't think i
can do it
um
i just gave up on the dream wow
i hope no one's listening to justin's uh
black that's encouraging um well thanks
um if you guys want to write in yeah we
would love to hear from you it's our
email addresses
life is short at wondery.com you want to
thank all the tale tims the short tim's
the kim's and the gyms i would love to
meet a short tim huge thanks to to tim
robbins um
for making the show a little classier
and i feel like i would say quite a bit
classier yes
and thanks to all of you guys for
listening and making it a show it
wouldn't be a show if we were just
talking to each other it's just supposed
to still be fun though it would be
really fun
uh and we would do it because it makes
us happy
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long and uh wait who produces it me oh
christian long yeah and megan monaco
that's right and the senior producer is
michelle michelans
who's our audio engineer marcelino
viapando executive producers are marcia
louis and ernan lopez for who wandery
goodbye see you next week
[Music]
sometimes it makes me sad though andy
being gone
i've got to remind myself that some
birds aren't meant to be caged
their feathers are just too bright
and when they fly away the part of you
that knows it was a sin to lock them up
does rejoice
but still the place that you live in is
that much more drab and empty now that
they are gone
i guess i just miss my friend
you